[Music]
november is a beast of a month when it
comes to new video games the christmas
rush begins and we all decide what santa
will bring us this year like usual this
is a video series where we look at new
video games and all price ranges are
covered and i've somehow found a few
free games to tide you over too so new
video games for november let's do this
only last week a trilogy of games was
revealed to be releasing in november
grand theft auto the trilogy the
definitive edition it's been 20 years
since gta 3 opened our minds to the
potential of a fully open 3d world
filled with criminal shenanigans it was
a phenomenon at the time which many
people watching this right now have
never played it's that old this was then
followed up with vice city a spin on the
miami vice 1980s vibe becoming a
criminal kingpin and then gta san
andreas brought us to la in the 90s on
the cusp of gang wars and the evolution
of rap music all three games have been
remastered but retain their original art
style new lighting updated fidelity and
tweaks to the gameplay system which were
desperately needed i mean 15-20 years
ago if we failed a mission we were
forced to drive across the map again to
restart it that was not fun but now
that's not an issue at all all three of
these games averaged above 9 out of 10
with san andreas being one of the
highest rated games of all time the real
question for most gamers now is which
one do you start with i'm gonna go with
by city if you're into this game because
i really am i'll be back later this
month with easter eggs and secrets you
can find in all three games so please
come back for that gta the definitive
edition releases digitally on november
11th on ps4 ps5 xbox one xbox series x
pc and even nintendo switch
[Music]
it wouldn't be november time without
call of duty taking the limelight this
time around it's vanguard the 18th game
in the series vanguard takes the first
person shooter back to world war ii as a
top secret international special forces
unit fight off the reich to end the war
like always you'll be globetrotting with
missions in europe the eastern bloc and
even north africa this time the
multiplayer element remains the core of
call of duty with vanguard releasing
with 20 maps and all the game modes that
make kob the leader in this genre zombie
mode returns again this year and
continues the dark ether storyline which
will actually be a prequel or prologue
to the black ops cold war story that
story is getting quite confusing but the
community around zombies is absolutely
massive call of duty vanguard hits
playstation xbox and pc on november the
5th
this year cod has a rival the return of
battlefield battlefield 2042 brings the
series back up to modern times and
there's a host of changes to hopefully
see battlefield compete with call of
duty some are really impressive like
freaking wing suits in a storm and
others aren't so great like the decision
to remove the campaign portion of
battlefield to concentrate solely on
multiplayer other changes see the class
system adapted into specialists with
unique special abilities battlefield
2042 offers 128 player game modes with
huge scale wars the size and scope is
awe-inspiring if you're on last-gen ps4
and xbox one you should know that those
machines are locked to 64 players with a
much smaller map but all modes offer
revolution the potential that the map
and the terrain changes as you play i'm
sure you've seen the typhoon which
engulfs the island mid-game sucking
players and vehicles into a swirling
hell hole it doesn't always happen but
there is a chance battlefield has other
ways to stand out including a mode which
is like escape from tarkov as you and
your squad go into a location in order
to recover intel picking up equipment
and then getting out of there as soon as
possible the problem is other teams of
real players are here too and should you
die in the field you lose all the items
on your corpse the risk reward game mode
has the potential to be super addictive
and finally a game mode which lets the
users create games designing almost all
elements if you wanted a game mode of
defibrillators versus knives you can do
that what about 99 ai opponents versus
two humans that's possible too the
potential is limitless battlefield
releases on november 19th on playstation
xbox and pc
[Music]
as we are already speaking about war
here's a free game you should know about
remember a few months ago i showed you
enlisted at the time it was only
available on next-gen machines and the
comment section wasn't too happy about
that well i bring you better news this
time enlisted is now on ps4 and xbox one
so if you haven't made the jump to the
next gen yet you're not going to miss
out on this free-to-play game right now
so if you need a fix of world war two
unless it is here the key difference
about enlisted is that you actually
control a squad of soldiers not just one
if a single player dies mid fight you'll
simply switch to another one in that
unit enlisted is right in the middle of
arcade ease and simulation realism and
their attention to detail in the way
weapons handle is certainly based in
realism but you still have the potential
to 360 no scope someone if that's your
jam it's out now if you want to try it a
different take on war huh good god y'all
remember last month i told you about
blood hunt battle royale coming to
console by the end of the year another
free-to-play game yeah well it's still
not here at the time of recording and
i've also asked for an update on this
and they confirm it will release in 2021
so that's about 70 days left of the year
i'd love to say it's coming in the next
week or two but i honestly have no idea
maybe if i stop bringing it up it'll
actually release
either way keep your eye out for the
vampire battle royale game hitting
consoles later this month oh one last
thing about free games if you're here
for ps plus games i'm unable to talk
about them until wednesday but i can say
there will be six this month three of
which are psvr games so dust that off
and we'll chat more about that on
wednesday
[Music]
what are your thoughts on sherlock
holmes this november a new multi-part
series releases all about that super
sleuth set when sherlock was only 21
years old we take control of him on an
open world island we are told that there
is no hand holding in this game allowing
us to pick up quests and do whatever we
like using our detective skills i'm
getting heavy la noir vibes from this
sherlock is accompanied by john who acts
like our moral compass our relationship
with jon is constantly shaping and
should we fail too often or murder too
many people instead of arrest them jon's
opinion of sherlock will change
impacting the story supposedly the
gameplay is so open almost any npc can
be spoken to interrogated and blamed and
yes it's possible to accuse the wrong
person of a crime and the game will
continue i'll be blaming jon for
everything because he's so judgmental
sherlock holmes chapter one releases on
november 16th on ps5 xbox series and pc
with ps4 and xbox one versions following
very soon
[Music]
back in 2018 jurassic world evolution
released a management sim in the veins
of roller coaster tycoon crossed with
zoo tycoon it did so well that it's back
with a sequel with the inspirationally
titled jurassic world evolution 2 well
you'll be building a home for all your
dinos and attracting visitors to your
park but of course nothing ever goes to
plan perfectly and some aggressive
dinosaurs will escape and start eating
all the herbivores you'll be rerouting
circuitry and managing every aspect of
your park while singing the theme tune
from the movies okay i added that last
bit jurassic world evolution 2 releases
on november 9th on playstation xbox and
pc
[Music]
so we started this video with a
remastered game from over a decade ago
and we're finishing this video with a
remastered game from over a decade ago
this is skyrim it's here again to
celebrate 10 years skyrim will release a
remastered version of the 2016 version
of the game on next gen consoles and pc
skyrim is without a doubt one of the
greatest rpgs ever created with one of
the most compelling storylines too the
community creation club is being
embraced in this version of the game
with over 500 elements created by the
public now available including fishing
because what else do you do when you're
not shouting at dragons or taking arrows
to the knee okay honest question now do
you own skyrim have you bought it more
than once i now have it three times and
i'm not sure if that's a flex or an
admission of guilt okay so we've made it
to the end is anyone still here probably
not like usual i have a question for you
after last month we did movie quotes
this time i want you to explain a
movie's plot badly and i'll try and
guess what it is this could go very
wrong but i'm up for the challenge i'm
adam you're awesome i'll see you soon
bye-bye
[Music]